le bouclier prend le monde tel qu'il n'est pas tel que
nous aimerions qu'il soit ce n'est pas la
liberté c'est la peur j'ai rejoint le bouclier pour protéger les
gens
dans ce film l'histoire de steve rogers est
vraiment la suite de son voyage
dans le monde moderne qu'il a commencé  dans
les vengeurs, il a un peu un dilemme moral en
travaillant pour nick fury et shield
il se méfie un peu des motivations des gens
quand ils l'approchent nous
allons neutraliser beaucoup de menaces avant
même qu'elles ne se produisent
je pensais que la punition venait généralement
après le crime
ce film traite de
théories du complot ce genre d'élément de grand frère
vous savez comment le jeu fonctionne
guerre de désordre tout ce qu'il faut c'est qu'un
cap arrive à un certain point dans le film
où il ne sait pas à qui il peut faire confiance
parfois la personne dont vous avez besoin  la confiance
est un étranger l'europe c'est fait
le faucon travaille avec le capitaine américain
et le suit à travers cette épreuve
parce qu'il le croit
juste au moment où vous pensez que les capps acceptent le
fait que sa vie antérieure est partie l'
ol  d la vie entre et le frappe au
visage sous la forme du soldat sorceleur
il y a une certaine quantité de mystère qui
émerge j'ai trouvé cela vraiment attirant